pour le moment on a on a un truc à finir
parce que hashtag toc toc toc pour
l'instant c'est julien courbet qui est
encore en tête
je sais que vraiment vous tenez à cette
séquence
donc on a trois toc toc toc à faire
quand même autour de johnny sachez qu'on
essaiera de les faire avant 21h45
qu'est ce que vous faites en régie non
mais je dois truc ait pas rêver c'est un
micro il ya un micro il ya un mec qui
parle en régie ou bien mais cavale et un
micro en fait tout simplement parce
qu'il ya des gars qui bouffent des
micros pendant les jours alors attention
va faire le toc toc toc c'est bon vous
êtes prêt j'appelle isabelle morini bosc
oh my god isabelle morini bosc a lésé
qui hélas ces gens gens qui aiment la
cible oublie ses boys à elle revenir
venait rappelle jean luc lemoine
dans le cloud allez-y beau jean-luc
totok qui est là omar remarquer au mari
savait où le mâle bondir au
téléspectateur ya quand même une
personne n'oublie qu'il a fait c'est
omar qui il ya quand même quelqu'un qui
est très premier degré qui fait omar sy
s'est passé de premières remarques qui
me passe par la tête quoi omar sy si tu
savais pas du bord de l'eau on a un
problème parce que quelqu'un qui soit
pour des mais colas qui déménage le
plateau la enora malagré dessous fait
franchement ce cas les copains qui vont
arriver des quatre autres ouais bah
c'est moi la place pour tout le monde
pour toute la série mais moi j'avais des
déménageurs bretons on n'a pas besoin de
vous en aller
le dernier gilbert baisse c'est parti
mon fils gilles toute attaque aux îles
tonga qui est la cgil bachil gilles qui
gilles verdez j'ai rien trouvé
[Applaudissements]
quoi ma gueule mais qu'est ce qu'elle a
ma gueule à remercier bob gainey temps
les roannais
on rigole on rigole mais il est arrivé
un drame dans l'équipe puisque bertrand
chamerois jamais roi
il s'est blessé lors d'un tournage pour
un prochain prime de ce qu'il fallait
détourné 1 le prime de parodies et nous
avons les images exclusives regarder la
chute la malheureuse chute de bertrand
chameau
et le pauvre bertrand donc c'est pas de
la vanne il s'est vraiment blessé à
l'épaule bertrand alors on a un message
du médecin de bertrand pour en savoir un
peu plus puisque il nous donne plus de
précisions sur son état actuel notre b
berck on embrasse faut regarder le rer
regarder non mais c'est vrai c'est fou
de voir un enfant comme ça de 6 ans cet
emprunt comme ça fait de la peine
on a pu aller rencontrer son médecin qui
nous a donné des nouvelles de bertrand
chamerois on sait que vous l'aimez
regard des professeurs la guerre vous
étiez de garde le jour de l'accident
oui oui c'est moi qui ai pris en charge
le patient je dois vous dire honnêtement
avec mon équipe quand on a vu la
blessure on était très très très inquiet
qu'après on a eu les résultats des
examens et là forcément on était
soulagés pourquoi parce que c'est une
simple fracture non parce que
d'innombrables c'était camille combal et
puis en fait non mais enfin je veux dire
non ça va quand même ça va quand même
impact et sur la qualité mais non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]